Hello. Welcome, everyone. My name is
John Ifraty,
and apparently I'm your expert for the afternoon.
Happy to meet anyone after the session.
The session's not really named great, so you don't get to meet me, but feel free to
meet me, and I'm not sure I'm an expert, but we'll be...
So
anyone who needs to access this online, please take a
shot of the 2D barcode right now, and we'll leave it up for another 20
seconds or so.
You can ask questions online,
and then we'll get started.
Welcome to the Meet the Expert session.
As I said, I'm John Ifraty. I'm a pathologist, a molecular diagnostician, and
cancer researcher, and we're going to talk tonight about
integrating digital pathology and AI with molecular
pathology.
Kind of a real exciting area of biomarker development,
and I'm going to give you my expert feeling about where the field
is going, what are the current challenges, and what are the current opportunities.
So hopefully it'll be fun.
Hopefully, some educational
parts, too. Here are my disclosures.
I won't be talking about any of these
during my talk.
Are there any pathologists in the audience? Do we have any pathologists?
Yeah, a couple.
One of my good friends sent me this last week.
CEO of America's largest public hospital system says he's ready to
replace radiologists with AI. So hopefully I have a job in
pathology when I get home, but certainly everyone is now asking me whenever
I see them, "How long
will pathologists be around?" Hopefully, after you hear this
session you'll realize we're close to doing some great things with AI
and probably pretty far for some other things.
But this is where the world thinks we are, but we're not.
As way of introduction, this was a really nice review from Behdad
et al. a few years ago from Cornell.
They talked about
what they saw, and I agree, is three general areas
where AI-integrated pathology is going to make a real difference.
One is the more simpler idea of workflow optimization.
They're just going to build very useful tools for image processing, image
analysis, quality control. I think those kind of tools will come and come quickly.
In the middle are decision support tools, maybe not
standalone like screening or biomarker black box
assays, but decision support, the ability to quantify aspects of
a slide like mitotic rate or tumor
percentages. Those kind of decision support tools, I think, and those of you who
are data scientists in the audience probably know more than I do, will come
quickly. They certainly have come in the field of radiology, where radiologists are
using decision support quite commonly now clinically.
And then digital biomarkers, and I include making primary diagnoses.
When will AI be ready to look at an H&E slide and just make a
diagnosis or predict a biomarker?
And there, I think, is what we're going to talk about.
Where are we really today to be able to do that?
Some of you in the field may have seen
some of the chatter a few weeks ago.
There was a controversial paper that came out from Dawood et al.
that said that AI models are cheating in biomarker development.
I think it's a really interesting paper.
I'll show some more details about it later, but it made a big
splash, certainly in the pathology community, that some of the AI
tools may not be as great as they are.
And they pointed out the importance of understanding confounding
elements in building AI models, and we'll talk about that.
So hyperreality, that's where we are with AI.
I think everyone would agree that's where we are in the world today.
So many of you probably know this hype curve figure, where you go
from innovation to the peak through trough of
disillusionment, slope of enlightenment. Where are we now?
I certainly think AI machine learning is at the very peak of inflated
expectations.
With that said, it might go even higher.
I predict it will go even higher.
Digital imaging
has been around for a while, and I think it went through the
trough of disillusionment a few years ago, and now we're beginning to
see utility in that and more pathology departments are
implementing it. And then finally, my field, which I would say if I'm an
expert in anything, it would be in molecular diagnostics.
We've reached this enlightenment
plateau of productivity. I've been working in the field of molecular diagnostics
since the early 2000s and have seen the field move through this
entire cycle.
In some ways, once you reach the plateau of productivity, things get a little more
boring. So maybe it's boring, but it's good because it means we're
actually productive and doing really meaningful things in the molecular
space. Okay. So I'm going to outline
what is my main question to talk to you about tonight.
What do I want this talk to focus on?
Can AI and H&Es predict actionable
mutations without genotyping? So for me, that's a big question because
my clinical business is molecular diagnostics.
So as pathologists, we know for many years certain mutations certainly correlate
with pathologists' recognizable morphological appearances.
I'll show you a few examples.
Foundation models are now coming fast and furious,
and they're easily available now.
I think it's reasonable from a scientific standpoint to expect that digital
image embeddings may include, quote, "yet
unrecognized information." So things that pathologists never recognize,
is AI seeing that? I think it's reasonable to expect that.
And if we could do this from H&E alone, we could save money
not having to do molecular. We could speed the results to our clinicians.
We can access targeted therapies and resources that don't have molecular, of
course.
And I think one utility that I think you see many of the
companies in this space focusing on in the beginning is providing data back
to... biotech companies to screen rare
genotypes for targeted therapy. So those kind of utilities, I think that last one,
you're probably going to see that used very soon.
Okay. For the data scientists in the audience, the first part is for you, and that
is, I'm going to set
for you where the bar is in the clinical expectations for molecular
performance.
And so I'm going to tell you mostly using some background
that I was very intimately involved with, which is the development of drugs against
EML4-ALK in non-small cell lung cancer.
I'm going to use some examples to illustrate what I'm talking about for
molecular performance. So we got involved in this soon after
Hiromu Mano's group in Japan described the EML4-ALK fusions.
Our lab had a FISH assay up here on the right.
We set up a FISH assay later that year.
That was 2007, late 2007. We already had a clinical grade
assay up and running that we began to screen patients, identify
patients who went on trial and showed remarkable responses.
As a pathologist, I looked at the slides that I was
identifying by FISH, the fusions, and they had interesting
morphologic correlates. Like, we could recognize this.
For the pathologists in the audience, you probably would say this is a little
unusual.
They're solid nests with signet ring cells embedded.
It's a unique picture for ALK-positive tumors,
and we recognize that. The ALK fusion biology, you
probably know, ALK is a receptor kinase.
It fuses together with EML4 in an inversion on chromosome 2.
So what we're looking for diagnostically is this inversion and then results in
this constituively active kinase.
And there are multiple methods for detecting this in the pathology lab.
I'm not going to go through them in gory detail other than you can use
immunohistochemistry, we can use FISH, we can use NGS.
There are FDA-approved assays for each one of those, and
behind this little statement is the hundreds and thousands and
thousands of hours of clinical lab efforts to get
there.
For instance, this is probably where it started.
This is a result of the Phase I study that our lab did the FISH for.
So this is the Phase I of crizotinib, and it's showing you the response rates
of around 57% in a Phase I study. You can see almost every patient
responded. Every patient on this trial was screened with an
ALK FISH assay, the same one, and we determined the performance characteristics of
the assay. And this became the gold standard for detecting
those patients, and then the predicate assay for anyone subsequent who wanted to
develop an assay. So you can see, this really is the gold
standard we expect from the performance of a diagnostic assay.
Did the patients respond?
And in this case, it was absolutely they did.
Again, for the data scientists, I'm going to show you
what a validation result looks like in a clinical lab.
This was,
not our attempt, our validation results in our MGH academic
lab as we moved from FISH to NGS.
So we had, using the predicate ALK FISH assay,
we developed an RNA-Seq assay
called anchored multiplex PCR, and you can see the performance characteristics
over here
are unbelievable. Right? When I'm
writing up a validation report, I'm always nervous to write this good of
performance because most people won't believe it.
But we have a sensitivity of 100%,
specificity of 99%, only because one of the FISH was indeterminate.
We could have dropped that out, and it would've been 100%, and the positive
predictive value is 100%. We'll come back to positive predictive
value. But for these kind of companion diagnostics,
what the clinicians want to know is, "If you're giving me a positive result and I
put a patient on that drug, I need to be confident 100% of the
time that it's correct."
So as you're probably hearing, I'm setting the bar higher and higher
for the expectations for a biomarker assay.
Based on a lot of sequencing work that we and others
did, the field developed, including Chugai in Japan,
developed second generation ALK inhibitors such as alectinib.
I'm showing you the results of the alectinib
early trial showing continued benefit in the setting of
crizotinib resistance. And then in the ALEX trial, head to head
improved survival, progression-free survival of alectinib.
We'll come back to this trial in a few slides.
And then finally for ALK, I think this is the home run slide for the field of ALK,
is the long-term results for the CROWN study, which is the latest
third generation lorlatinib
against crizotinib outcomes. And you can see the progression-free survival
in red of crizotinib is about nine months median
PFS, and we're out at six, seven, almost eight years
with lorlatinib single agent in advanced lung cancer.
And so an amazing amount of improvements here.
All of them backed up by diagnostic tests that perform at a high
level.
It's not just us. Every lab that launches these tests...
This is from the FoundationOne assay,
FDA-approved FoundationOne assay from the package insert.
They had to do the same type of correlative work and show a
performance characteristics that is at the same very high level using, in this
case, ALK IHC and FISH as the predicate assays, all of them built on
that original FISH assay. And so the expectations here are really
high. This is as of 2004, a list of FDA-approved companion
diagnostics.
All of these
done with the same level of rigor and expectations.
And then finally, I'd like to show this
slide,
which is a summary of proficiency testing.
So I served, some other folks in the audience, served on the
College of American Pathologists Proficiency Testing Committee,
which oversees samples that we send out to really every clinical
lab in the country,
in reality, in the world, that does tests for BRAF, EGFR, and
KRAS.And this is just showing you the passing score,
and what you see is 98, 99,
100% of labs
that do clinical testing are expected and do pass these proficiency
tests.
Okay.
That whole preamble part, this whole beginning part is just to tell everyone
what we expect from AI machine learning is clinical
grade, and that's clinical grade. All right. Everyone's with me.
So can we predict
mutations from H&Es?
There are some really interesting examples. I showed you ALK in the beginning.
This is a really seminal paper that came out of Johns Hopkins from
Stan Hamilton, Bert Vogelstein, showing the correlates of
microsatellite unstable colon cancer. This is back in '94.
On the right, many of the pathologists, or all the pathologists will know that
these MSI high colon cancers are poorly differentiated mucinous
tumors with lots of lymphoid infiltrates. That's just how they look.
It's been known for a long time. Do the pathologists in the audience
use this information clinically? Maybe a little bit.
Maybe a slight decision support, or they mention it in the clinical report
over the years, but at the end of the day, the gold standard was molecular
diagnostics and now immunohistochemistry.
But indeed, there are
human identifiable morphologic correlates.
Zoom forward to the modern era of foundation models.
This is work from Jakob Kather that he showed in his talk, which is a
2025 model that he built, trained on
publicly available colorectal cancer images and molecular data.
I'm showing you the annotations of those at the molecular level.
The training cohort at KRAS, APC, P53
mutations. This cluster too has MSI in it,
what we were just talking about. It's known that MSI tumors tend to be
BRAF mutation positive, so
there are biological correlates or
links. These are biological true links.
They're not confounding
links between these different genotypes.
But he trained his model
on these publicly available data sets,
and this is what the performance characteristics look like for what I would say is
a modern foundation model.
The best predictor that his group can see is actually
microsatellite instability with an AUROC or an AUC of about
0.9. Pretty impressive. And I think that's about the best
AUC that I've seen in any of these predictive models.
And I'm talking about a morphologic phenotype that is
actually pretty easy for pathologists to pick out.
So in the easiest, lowest
bar to pick out, machines are about AUC of
0.9.
It falls down to 0.6 or really down to
0.5 for things like NRAS or PIK3CA.
So these models can't perfectly be trained to do this.
One thing I like about Jakob's papers is he includes other metrics.
He includes this AUPRC, precision recall,
and you can see the precision recall is not as impressive.
It's pretty good for MSI, honestly, but it falls off also.
And we'll talk about what precision recall is in a few slides.
I think it's incredibly important.
He and a number of papers are now able to use their machines
to present to us the images that drove those predictive
models, and it's showing here a typical MSI-type phenotype in
the positive cases.
But I'll let you know, how useful will this be to pathologists?
Will we replace MSI testing with an H&E predictor?
We won't, because there are standard of care,
extremely good immunohistochemical markers that are used by all pathology labs in
the world, MLH1, MSH2/6, and PMS2.
They're a standard of care. In Lynch syndrome, they tell us
which of the
genes are mutated. In sporadic, it'll tell you the MLH1 is lost.
So we have really good assays.
So as of today, the best performing biomarker model
that I've seen
is a really interesting proof of concept, but likely is not going to change
the practice really at all.
Coming back to ALK, we did a couple of papers back in the day.
This is from 2012,
where we built,
using heuristics,
a model of predicting ALK in H&Es. One are the signet ring cell
morphologies that I mentioned before.
There's a few other morphologies like hepatoid pattern.
And interestingly, don't ask how we ended up with this model, but if
you had a small biopsy, that got you a few points in this model.
It's actually
not coincidental,
and this is where we begin to think about confounders in training models.
ALK patients, we know from the natural history of ALK patients, it's a highly
aggressive disease, at least in the US at presentation.
Almost all of the ALK patients present with metastases,
and so there is a statistical link with small
biopsies
for having ALK. So there is some statistical value there, and
we see that in other data sets.
Okay. Historically, I'm going to take maybe a step forward from
that 2012 to really what was, I think, the landmark
paper in the field for predicting genotypes, which was this paper out of NYU
from Kadri et al.,
using the Google neural network, Inception v3.
This is still an exciting paper. It was really
mind-blowing at the time because it was the first proof of concept that this could
be done with better than flipping a coin.
You can squeeze out mutational data out of
images. And they did a nice job in lung cancer predicting mutations.
Here you see EGFR and a few other mutations.
The AUCs for these studies are all about 0.7.
They're not 0.9, they're 0.7. This was exciting as a first step.
This paper deserves the credit that it gets.
They couldn't predict ALK. So that, they were unable to do.
They tried, but they were unable to in this paper.But again, this
paper deserves a lot of credit.
We can move past the 0.7 AUC threshold by implementing
some of these more modern self-supervised, pre-trained foundation
models. Obviously, you've seen at this meeting a ton of these now are available,
and there's whole sessions on these models.
They're obviously changing everything, and they're trained on huge
numbers of slides, thousands and thousands of slides, and we're hoping that they
now encode for information that maybe some of the earlier models
wouldn't. This recent paper I really enjoyed by Hsiao et al.,
there took the approach of combining
foundation models, kind of linking them together and trying to squeeze out even
more
value in the embeddings.
One thing I liked about the paper, they had a nice introduction which showed some
of the details about what these foundation models were trained on.
So they showed UNI from Boston, ProvGigaPath from
Microsoft and the Providence group in
Northwest, and then VirCow from Paige and PhyCon from
Oaken. You can see that there are geographical biases
on where these samples are taken and how they're trained.
When they look at the sample types that went into each of the foundation models in
this circos plot over here, you can see each one of the models is trained on a
different mix of tumor types. And so would we expect each of the models to be as
good
at each tumor type as maybe another one that had more in the pre-training set? No.
And I think over time, we'll eventually figure out how all this breaks
down. The ProvGigaPath foundation model had
this nice paper in 2024, again, predicting mutations
from
H&Es. This is one of the largest foundation models, and you can
see the prediction for, let's say, EGFR and P53 is reaching
this 0.7 to 0.8
AUC. So interesting and inching up, but not
clinical grade based on what I talked about.
I don't know if anyone got to see Dr.
Campanella's talk earlier at ACR.
I thought it was really impressive.
But his group
at Mount Sinai and Sloan Kettering in New York published this last year,
which is a deployment of the ProvGigaPath, the model I just showed you in the
previous slide, that foundation model.
It took that foundation model and then fine-tuned it.
Essentially what that means is they took that foundation model and then
continued to train it on Sloan Kettering EGFR mutant
data. So they added many, many more data points
from Sloan Kettering, and they began to push the AUC up towards
almost 0.9. This is a very impressive next step, I
think. I'm not going to talk about it,
but
the paper did something else really impressive, which is to show how you could use
a test like this in triaging cases clinically.
So I give them a lot of credit for taking that next step for how can we
use maybe a not perfect test, but use it and find clinical utility
in it. So I encourage everyone in the space, if you haven't read it, many of you
probably have, but if you haven't read it, this is a great paper.
So really cool.
The other thing I like that they did is they showed images and what were driving
some of the scores in their model, and we'll
talk about
this kind of ability to understand interpretability.
But I give them a lot of credit for taking that step to show us the images
and whether it's interpretable or not.
So I showed you this paper that joins foundation models.
I think the other exciting approach, of course, that we hear a lot about are
"multimodal models," which is taking
different data sets and bringing them together.
This paper just published in "MPJ Precision Oncology" is a
multimodal glioma predictor, which takes MRIs
that have been embedded using AI tools in radiology along
with the H&E embeddings and merging them together.
I am not a data scientist, as you probably can tell, and so I don't
understand all of the details about the architectures, but obviously, this
is going to squeeze more information than either one of them alone.
The other neat thing, similar to the Campanella paper,
is they use unsupervised approaches to pull out features,
common features that are statistically significant in each of their
diagnoses. They call them features, and they're listed here like F19, F20.
And then they can present it back to us as pathologists to look at and say, "That
feature was the main feature that drove it in this direction." It's almost like a
principal component analysis, how I would think about it, like what was driving
that PCA? These are the highest features that drive both histology and
radiology.
Obviously, there's a whole world of biomarkers.
I put these
HER2 slides just because of the incredible importance of HER2, but this is a really
nice paper from 2021 from Bychkov et al.
from Scandinavia, where they trained AI models to predict from
H&E HER2 copy number using SIS
images and training the model based on SIS.
They were able to show a positive
correlation here, but AUCs of 0.7 are not going to
replace standard of care FISH or IHC, which have been validated
on tens to hundreds of thousands of samples.
So suggesting you can push the technology a bit, but
definitely not ready for prime time.
Similar to Campanella et al., who showed the clinical utility of AI,
PathAI has now built a useful tool.
It may not be
groundbreaking new AI, but it is useful, and it's
quantifying immunochemical stains for
pathologists from slides. And there is definitely value to
making IHC more reproducible and standardized, both for
pathologists, clinicians, and pharma.
So these kind of tools, which you might put in the decision support
tool...
are, I think, going to come, and they're going to be useful.
So I don't mean to be glass half empty for a lot of this.
There are definitely tools that I think we're going to deploy, and deploy soon.
I mentioned this Dawood paper in the beginning of my talk, which kind of
exploded out in the field a couple of weeks ago, where they talked about
confounders. I'll spend the next few minutes talking about confounders.
One that they talked about is if you have multiple biomarkers, those may
be confounding when you're linking them to an H&E stain.
And in one example, they showed colon cancer.
I don't think this was the best example because, as I showed you earlier,
some mutations, like BRAF and MSI are linked.
They're biologically associated.
They're not confounders, and so you wouldn't be able to separate them out.
But nonetheless, this paper is worth reading, I think, for sure, because it
really brings to the foreground what I think is going to be required to keep moving
the foundation, not foundation models, these predictive models forward, which is
understanding the source of confounding and bias
in models.
For the non-pathologists in the audience,
you have to understand a little bit about the type of samples we see in pathology.
The TCGA samples, for instance, which many models are built on,
are built on the highest quality H&E slides resections,
whole tumor resections. I'm showing you one here and one here.
These are beautiful slides of the entire tumor.
The computer gets to learn about the whole tumor.
But the number of less than optimal samples that come to pathology is
extremely large, and the expectation that foundation models or any of these models
are going to be able to handle, like this bloody sample I'm showing you here,
or this one over here, or these two samples here, which are actually cell
blocks, which are fluids outside of the tissue architecture.
They're just not going to translate, and they're not going to be able to learn.
And many models don't even train in cytologic samples.
So the number of times we get these in pathology is a lot, and the
expectation that the performance is going to be as high as the high-quality
samples that train the foundation model, I think is
a little naive.
I'm giving it just side by side for the non-pathologists.
This is what a tissue tumor looks like with a signet ring cell here.
This is what they look like floating in fluid.
They're completely different, and if you think about what a computer would need to
do to measure lines and embeddings and contrast,
they're just going to learn different things.
And so we're going to have to make the steps back to improve the training models.
One of my postdocs, Tom Bisson, recently decided to build an ALK
predictor using really kind of modern, up-to-date,
but standard tools like CONCH, embedding tool from
a foundation model from
Faisal Lemmu's lab and multiple instance learning.
We got an AUC of 0.86. Sounds really good.
But if you look at the other performance characteristics, it's really not that good
of an assay, and precision-recall here is poor.
So for the non-data scientists, this is probably going to be
interesting.
Does anyone know what-- The non-data scientists know what
precision-recall is? It sounds very fancy.
So precision actually, for the clinicians out there, is positive predictive
value, renamed as precision. So data scientists know it as precision.
We know it as positive predictive value.
And I think translating between our two worlds is important.
And then recall is sensitivity.
So all I'm telling you, which the clinical lab people in the audience
know, is you can't just judge a test based on sensitivity and
specificity. You actually have to know positive predictive value, negative
predictive value, reproducibility.
And so I'm holding the bar high for the data scientists in the
audience
that your papers have to include things like AUPRC as well as
AUROC and think about other aspects of it.
Maybe one second on positive predictive value.
As you tune your assay and the cutoffs of your assay to capture more
patients, that is to have a higher sensitivity because you want to
screen for patients and find all of them.
As you make that cutoff
more loose, that you get more patients, the chance of any
positive being true positive begins to fall.
So you begin to have this inverse relationship with positive predictive value.
And as I said in the beginning, clinicians don't like when you have false
positives. If you tell them that the patient has an EGFR mutation, and they don't,
they get very upset with pathology, like really upset,
as do patients.
Coming back to explainability.
The data scientists in the audience probably do know this, but many
of you won't. I really like this example for explainability.
It's an example of four distributions of data, 11 data points on an
XY coordinate.
And what's interesting about these 11 points is to a
human who looks at them, they're very different data sets.
No one would think immediately that these are related at all.
However, statistically, if you asked a machine, are they related,
the machine would tell you their X coordinates, mean, and variance, their Y
coordinates, mean, and variance, and their regression lines are exactly the same.
Right? That kind of blew my mind the first time I saw this.
And so to expect a machine to understand what things look like based
on statistical embeddings is just something I think we all
have to be aware of. And as pathologists, I like to go back and look
at things. And so at least for the next few years, I think we're going to have to
work very closely together, that is data scientists and pathologists, to
work through where we might have confounders and things like this.
This is one of very interesting examples
that I've seen, which is a really interesting paper from 2018, which showed
taking pictures of skin lesions, whether they're melanoma or not.
And
what was confounding in this study was the patients who had malignant melanoma had
a rulerNext to their melanomas on their skin.
And the machine learned if there was a ruler next to the skin
lesion that they had melanoma.
And it makes sense. Why wouldn't a machine-- that's the shortest cut, probably the
most accurate way to detect a melanoma.
But it's,
I don't know. There's these blatant examples that you can see for pathologists
circling. Did you circle or an arrow on a slide? Those kind of things.
Coming back to
my post-doc's ability to build an ALK predictor, he pulled out
using one of these unsupervised explainability
tools. What were the
patches that drove the prediction?
On the right,
for the pathologists, hopefully, you recognize there's a lot of signet ring cells,
and that was good because that's really something we see in
ALK-positive slides. These are all fluids, by the way.
So we see that we had a lot of fluids in our data set.
But on the left, the
patches on the left were also driving this predictor.
And the pathologists in the room will definitely say, "That is nothing." There
is nothing useful in any of those slides, in any of those patches.
What you see are fragments of bone, a lot of blood,
sometimes nothing.
And so what is that? I think this is coming back to, if you remember the predictor
I had in our old heuristic model,
is these are what you would see in a needle
biopsy of a metastatic lesion. We often see these
poor, small, fragmented, bloody samples.
And so, yes, it's actually contributing to the ALK-positive calls.
What other issues are there in building these models?
Let me do a time check quickly.
Oh, we still have time. Okay.
Talk too much.
Can I take a drink? Do you mind? Give me one second.
Besides confounding bad, horrible pathology slides,
what else can confound the development of
these models? Well, we have entities in pathology and medicine that
are super rare, that are probably never represented in the foundation model
slides. Despite there being 100,000 or a million slides,
each with a billion pixels,
they didn't have all of them. And so I'm just showing you one disease, which is
bone and soft tissue sarcomas,
for which
there's what we call a long tail of rare entities.
This is the current WHO. There's 170 recognized soft tissue
tumors. Do you think all of them are represented sufficiently to build a foundation
model that fully embeds all of the unique features?
And even though there are 170
different chapters in this book, I guarantee you each one of those
has 10 unique histologic subtypes or
slightly different features.
So we just don't have enough of these rare entities to replace the
pathologist.
The problem can be approached by this, quote, "zero-shot
methods that incorporate vision language," and
Faisal's CONCH model did that. So it was trained not just on images, but
also on language. So presumably, the WHO textbook was
taken in by his model, and so maybe it could just read the chapter and
fill in the missing morphologic information in his model. So that's possible.
But I think larger dedicated training sets from cooperative efforts and federated
learning is going to be required, and I think that's something AACR, for
instance, can be involved with. And some of us have talked about how to
begin to build these kind of federated models.
I showed you a few examples where AI doesn't have to be perfect.
I'm asking you to be perfect on some things, but AI doesn't have to be perfect on
everything.
And a good example of a test that doesn't have to be perfect is ctDNA.
If you remember the CROWN study I showed you.
So there was a secondary analysis of those samples, which
is using ctDNA, using the Guardant360, a very
common, well-validated assay for ctDNA.
And in the two cohorts, the lorlatinib and the crizotinib cohort, what I'm
showing you is Guardant only identified the fusion from blood in
about half the cases.
So sensitivity at 50%. That's not really good.
According to what I've been telling you all along, it's not very good.
However, that's not the clinical use for this assay here.
It's a monitoring assay. So if you can actually identify those patients, you can
now monitor them longitudinally.
So not a perfect assay, but clinically useful.
So I think we'll find common ground there.
The last 10 minutes, I'm going to transition from H&E mutation
to what I think is a really exciting new world of spatial data.
And how are we going to move
from multiplex immunofluorescence and spatial transcriptomics to
clinical applications? I think for me, from a research
standpoint, extremely exciting, but is there a road
forward to bring those technologies
into the clinic?
Many of you, I think, have done or used immunoprofiling.
Annie Li, one of my post-docs, produced these images.
This is a sarcoma where we're showing you just these beautiful pictures
where half the tumor on the right here is class I positive,
half the tumor on the left is class I negative, and we're studying immune
infiltration and immune evasion using these technologies.
Really, really interesting. You can build now 20, 30,
40 protein panels.
Studying this for research is great. Could we use some of this clinically?
Perhaps there'll be predictors
of immune
checkpoint response, or perhaps we can now mix
standard diagnostic markers at a scale that is now
clinically useful.
The critical step in taking these immunofluorescenceTwo
analyses is segmentation of cells and cell type classifiers.
I think it's probably a dirty secret for those of us who do this that these are not
solved problems despite, I
don't know, 30 years. I see David around.
I know he's the expert in this field. But he knows the problem.
It's something he's been working on for probably 20, 30
years. And so can we use AI now to help with segmentation and
cell type classification? I think absolutely yes.
But right now it involves a huge amount of manual
intervention by the people that are running these assays and then
QC'ing them and preparing them for downstream analysis.
It's not
scalable if you have 20, 30, 40 markers to think this is going to be clinically
useful, at least right now.
So that's multiplex IF.
Spatial transcriptomics, equally as exciting.
We can now do a whole transcriptome. I just saw the new 10X instrument.
You can do the whole transcriptome at thousands of transcripts per cell.
We used it in the same setting I showed you in the prior slide to begin to
understand class one high and low areas and be able to predict that.
You can use unsupervised clustering to be able to understand the
spatial distribution of these things. Super exciting.
Are we ready for prime time clinically with some of these things?
Could you use some of this clinically?
Not sure.
Well, I am sure. No, not yet.
I'm going to skip over this slide. Obviously, you can use all this Visium data to
create these amazing UMAPs
and then to identify differential gene expression.
This is what we're doing in these different areas of immune presentation.
But the challenges
that remain for clinical applications of spatial
approaches
are obvious to those of us who do it. The throughput remains really low.
I don't know any lab that can afford to do maybe more than three or four Visium
runs a week. The amount of money that that costs is
several thousand dollars per sample. Throughput is low. It's just too low.
Cost is high.
The data remains sparse for transcriptomics.
It's not true single-cell resolution.
We often get just hundreds of transcripts per cell.
The image processing remains, as I said, a problem of segmentation and
thresholding.
With all that said, the innovation remains rapid, and a couple of things
I think everyone's excited about, certainly I'm excited about, is combining
immunofluorescence with transcriptomics and then also with H&E.
You can now overlay all three of these things. Multiple vendors use them.
We have this current project with Singular Genomics, who's
here, where you can do combination of an 18-plex
immunofluorescence panel with a 500-plex transcriptomics.
They overlay that with an H&E.
I am excited about Singular right now because of one big difference with the
other companies, and that's throughput.
So you can do, as I'm showing you down here on the left, you can do
10 samples per slide,
and a technician in the lab can easily do
two of these slides a day,
so can easily do 20 samples a day. And there is the first time
I've seen a platform that's beginning to get the throughput that a clinical
laboratory would need. You'd need multiple instruments now and multiple
technicians, but it's finally moving in that space.
Visium, or we run a lot of Lunaphore, there's no
current road forward for the clinical throughput for any of those.
Machine learning and AI, and that's really what I want to focus on.
However, it's helping drive these improvements, and I think we really
see some exciting changes here.
Those of you who are in the field probably know CellPose out of the Broad.
This uses AI to help with the segmentation problem.
Chronos is a foundation model out of
Sizun Zheng and Faisal Mahmood's lab, which
is,
I would say, the equivalent of a patch-based H&E foundation model.
It's patch-based immunofluorescent encoder.
So it's taken hundreds of thousands of immunofluorescence
images,
split them into patches, and then built a
statistical model around those. That's really exciting.
There are other new AI,
you call them foundation models for cell classification.
Nimbus is one that we're super excited about from
the lab of Michael Angelo at Stanford,
and I'm showing you here a little bit of the details from the Nimbus paper, one
of the best papers I've read in a long time.
So if anyone in this presentation wants to
take anything away, it would be probably to read this paper.
But they did a few little tricks that allow them to improve
the cell classification over other methods, and that is to take into account
not just cell segmentation here, but also the
spatial distribution within that segmented region of the
immunofluorescent signal. And so some patterns
are just biologically implausible, and that is when you have
two cells overlapping. A major problem with cell segmentation and
classification is overlapping cells.
But this model kind of
weights down those cells that have strange spatial distribution of
immunofluorescence and then weights up cells that have a clean distribution of
either membranous or cytoplasmic staining.
So you can take two cells that look quite similar in their
fluorescent intensity if you averaged all of the intensity over that segmented
cell. But now with these weights driven by AI, you now
get a nice bimodal distribution, and developing a cutoff becomes quite easy.
So a neat, cute paper-- It's not a cute paper.
It's an impressive paper that I think is really changing our
lab workflow, and I would say the nice thing about it is it works.
So this is my last slide. This is courtesy of my postdoc, Tom, about
what a modern, I think, integrated workflow could look like,
which we're moving towards in the research space, but I could see it
clinically.Taking clinical data,
structured data, and passing that along with H&Es with H&E
foundation model
embeddings
together with multiplex immunofluorescence, where you have patch level
encodings but also cell type encodings, single
cell encodings, and
annotations. And finally, the spatial transcriptomic data,
merging these together to answer the specific questions that you
would have.
So this is what we're working on. I think this is where the field is moving.
I think all of this data together will be rich enough to indeed predict meaningful
clinical biomarkers that we want.
What's the cost? What's the throughput?
How does it compare to all the other stuff that we as pathologists do?
That's our job to do together. But, I'm going to leave you on this more
positive note that I think we're going to do some really awesome things together,
but it's going to require working together.
So summary is my summary slide. There will be an avalanche of
AI tools to predict mutations from H&Es. There are a ton of papers.
I think they're just going to keep coming because they're now quite easy to do with
all the foundation models and multiple instance learning.
I'm going to argue to everyone in the audience, we need rigorous performance
metrics more than we're currently using.
Standards and benchmarks, a clear understanding of confounders
before implementing any of these things.
We're going to see multimodal models.
That includes radiology and pathology or multiple
tissue-based diagnostics.
As a general statement, I don't think we're going to replace molecular diagnostics
with H&E
predictors alone. We're going to have to work together,
and so it'll incorporate molecular diagnostics rather than replace it.
And then I showed you some really cool, most modern applications of
AI machine learning to spatial transcriptomics and NIF.
I thank you for my attention. I'm going to thank you for my lab group,
who're just wonderful to work with.
But thank you everyone in the audience for
staying late and listening to my talk. I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you.
Or feel free to come down.
Hey, John.
Dr. Rim.
Great talk. Thanks.
But one of the things that's always troubled me that, as you talked about at the
end of your talk, is the inclusion of
multiplex fluorescence into the model ultimately, and
integrating it with AI and things like that.
What do you think the reproducibility is of multiplex fluorescence, and how do you
make it reproducible?
For those of you who don't know Dr. Rim, he is probably the world's expert in
reproducibility of immunofluorescence .
So I certainly don't have the right answer for you.
There are
pre-analytical variables, and I think this is probably what you're hinting
at. There are pre-analytical values that will affect the fluorescence intensity,
and quality from slide to slide.
I give the H&E field credit for developing
these
pre-model corrections for intensity, color correction,
and all of those things. Most likely there'll be-- and I'd like to hear from
you. I think
it makes the most sense to use
pre-model image corrections to normalize that
data in a way that you remove them
as confounders in the models. I think based on what H&E folks
have done, that should be eminently possible.
No, that's good. I agree 100% with that,
but I still worry that
when you talk about multiplex fluorescence, there's so many variables that we
don't control.
Yeah.
And
how the antibodies behave with each other, and how you mix them together and what
order you mix them in are all variables that are really hard to control.
And if we mix them all together and use data from one
institution and data from another, that even if they've used the exact same
antibodies-
Yeah
... on the exact same platform, my guess is they're not reproducible.
Yeah. Perhaps it's doing a better job of developing
these as CLIA FDA type
tools where we have better understanding of the pre-analytical variables, which
we've done a good job in HER2 in breast, but obviously we'd have to do across the
board, and it's going to be hard with bone biopsies and other fluids.
Thank you.
Thank you for the talk. I hope you forgive my ignorance on the topic.
I think where
it seemed to start was using histology to predict mutations.
Yes.
And then I think towards the end, we started talking about spatial
transcriptomics-
Yes
... where we're getting back into the genetic information.
Yes.
And I think what I'm not able to connect is what does the
spatial transcriptomics add on top of traditional
diagnostics that you wouldn't get from just scraping the area and-
Yeah. Good. Thank you for asking that. I think that's an important question.
I guess I'm talking more abstractly about the development of biomarkers,
and in this setting,
it could be a black box
biomarker that's a combination of multiple RNAs that now
predict--
Simplest would be like immunotherapy response. That's the holy grail.
But you could imagine incorporating spatial and immunofluorescence data to
any kind of predictor that you want.
What is the task you want to accomplish?
What I think I was trying to convey is probably you can squeeze a lot out of
H&E,
but in most tasks, it won't be sufficient,
right?
You don't think we could get that from just sequencing or doing
whatever omics on
that part of the slide that we're interested in?
Do we need the spatial information?
I guess I'm just not connecting where the spatial part-
I think you'reI was talking again more
abstractly.
Uh-huh.
I do think in many of the cases, standard of care molecular diagnostics
will remain-
Okay
... the main way to identify patients who respond to ALK inhibitors, EGFR
inhibitors.
But this is more discovery related, or is this clinically-
I think what I'm talking about is we're going to continue as a field-
Uh-huh
... to develop by... When people say biomarker-
Yeah
... they generally use it in an abstract term.
Okay.
They want to predict clinical outcome.
They want to predict X, Y, or Z things, and that's what
I'm talking about, is the use of a biomarker.
But if we want to talk about specific tasks,
I agree with what you're saying, and I tried to make that point in the beginning.
Things like ALK, EGFR,
BRAF, we have tests that are really good at those, and we're unlikely to replace
that with spatial information.
All right, cool.
How will the spatial data come into play? Not just...
Because we can do RNA sequencing. We've been able to do that for, since
Affy chips.
What does the spatial information bring to biomarkers?
We don't have great examples yet where
the spatial technologies are changing
a clinical predictor, like we built a clinical predictor out of it.
But I think everyone who's here doing research in this space thinks we have to
continue to do that, and we'll try and uncover as much information.
So
it's kind of making the assumptions that that information will be helpful to
us. But you're right, it might not be.
We may get as much as we need.
I know. I'm just asking. I'm not claiming.
I'm just curious your thoughts on it. Yeah.
Okay. It's a good question.
Thank you.
Thank you, Professor Yakovra. My question is
similar to the previous question.
That's, the gene mutation prediction
performance promising that we can go further to predict the
subtype of the exact specific mutation type?
Like the, not only the KRAS gene mutation, but also the
KRAS G12D or G12C, something that-
Yes
... is a clinical useful, the predictor.
Of course, they're
useful. And there are some hints
that the different types of mutations have different histologic appearances.
And we know this from lung cancer. A G12D lung cancer is often
mucinous in appearance.
Yes.
And so there's morphologic correlates of that.
But I agree with the last
questioner's approach. Like some of these things,
sequencing is just the way to do it.
But if you think about biomarkers in the abstract, integrating that mutation data
now with spatial data may give you new subtypes of
G12C mutant lung cancer, some of which respond well
to G12C inhibitors, some which
don't respond as well. See what I mean?
So being able to now subclassify them, I think is where we would
want to use that kind of data. But to ask the simple task,
does it have a G12C or G12D? We have an assay.
There's 10,000 papers showing validation of assays that do that, and there's no
reason to spend $3,000 a slide to reinvent the wheel.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hi, I'm Christiana Friedenberg, University of Florida.
I'm a pathologist, a physician scientist.
I have a lab, but I also focus on head and neck and cardiothoracic
pathology.
Mm-hmm.
So,
I don't understand, right-- I love AI. I love digital pathology.
I think it's great. I think we need it not only in the biomarker
space, but actually to great intensity-
Mm-hmm
... because pathologists are very subjective.
Yep.
So I really
understand the power in that way. But I don't understand this H&E
prediction thing, right, of mutations, because it's really
hard to have your clinicians, your
oncologists already trust what's out there.
Yes.
So now they want to add another-
Yes
... level of complexity to what we have to build the trust
again. And then you have community pathologists who have to
somehow now pick up something new, right?
And so I remember when molecular
pathology came out, and everyone's like: "Your job is over.
They're going to do everything by molecular." "They don't need anatomic
pathologists anymore." And then all they needed us to do was circle now.
Now they need us even more, right?
Yeah.
Because now they have all this data that-
Yeah
... is molecular driven that they don't know what to do with because everything is
overlapping.
Yeah.
So why do we need the H&E thing? Just-
Yeah. Great
... let's just stick with molecular like NGS.
Yeah. It's a great question. I think my point in the beginning was we
probably don't, in the short term, need that.
But you're going to see so many papers on the topic.
I wanted this audience-
Yeah
... to understand why people are doing that.
They're doing it because they can, and it's interesting.
Yeah.
But for those of us on the front lines,
it's noise.
It is. Yeah.
And it's confusing-
It is
... the people who use what we do. However, I'll spin it around and give you a
different view of the world, which is decision support.
Let's say, is your lab digital?
Not completely.
Let's say your lab's completely digital, and you have your cockpit in front of you,
and you have your H&E, and you have your AI tools, which say, "90%, this
is non-small cell lung cancer. By the way, there's
a 78% chance it's EGFR mutation. You should get that ordered
today."
Yeah.
I can definitely see a set of useful probability tools
as pathologists that are going to come up on our screen that are going to be like,
"You should be concerned this is
a lung cancer. Maybe that was a wrong diagnosis," or, "There's a probability
that this is X, Y, or Z." And those little
probabilities will come to us, I think, on our cockpit screens,
and we will incorporate them the way we incorporate all of the other
information we have, whether it's clinical information or stains or whatever.
So I can imagine a day where a probability of a mutation would help you
and help the patient get the right test a little bit quicker.
And so I don't think we should push against it.
We just need to work together to find the use
cases-To do this. The Campanella paper I showed is a neat
paper I mentioned-
Yeah
... because they didn't say, "We're going to replace molecular." They said, "At
Sloan Kettering, we're going to triage every lung cancer quickly to know
whether they need rapid EGFR testing so that they can go on to
osimertinib as quick as possible." I like that.
That is a practical approach.
Whether it's really going to be useful, we'll see in perspective studies.
Yeah, I think the reliability, though.
I know that some people are not as intuitive as pathologists, let's say,
at Memorial Sloan Kettering or in MDH, right?
Because I see a lot of community pathologists.
Yes.
So an over-reliance is my concern as well.
Agree.
That they won't even do the right-- They'll just go, "Oh, it said it, so let's just
go ahead and make it easy." You know what I'm saying?
Totally agree.
So a lot of education has to happen for pathologists, in my
opinion.
I want us to be part of it, though, right?
Yeah, of course. I'm all for it.
Yeah, I want pathologists to engage more into this topic
rather than let the wave... The wave is coming
over us,
and I think we need to be
upfront telling people what we really need. Yes.
Hi. JD Alvarez, Daiichi Sankyo. Just following up
on this discussion here.
For HER2 overexpression in lung cancer, it's rare,
but there is an approved drug for that.
And what we are finding is that the test doesn't get
ordered.
Yes.
But if there was an H&E predictor-
Yes
... that increased the probability that this particular sample would
be positive-
That's great
... for HER2 IHC, that may be something that could be beneficial
and-
Yes
... cause testing. But actually, my question was about
H&E predictors of spatial transcriptomics and spatial
proteomics-
Mm-hmm
... because I just saw a big session-
Yes
... where there were a lot of tools.
I just wanted to see what your thoughts were on that.
I think it's all very early, but the technologies now,
those images can now be overlaid very accurately,
and we can begin to compute on all of those layers together.
As I said, bringing them together into a single model, I think is super
exciting.
Whether that allows us to squeeze more valuable information together,
we'll see. But yes, many sessions focus on that and
building those tools today. But it'll take time to figure out is
it worth the cost and the time. I think that's
really what we'll see. But thank you for your first comment.
I did point out that the value of AI in clinical trial
identification, and I do think in biotech, the
ability to give a probability of a rare genotype like
you're talking. It's not rare HER2, but other rare genotypes.
Let's say your institution has a trial open to be able to identify
this patient who would not have otherwise gotten testing,
has an 83% chance of having a,
I don't know,
whatever RB mutation. Whatever mutation is going to be valuable to the
drug development community.
So with the task of predicting mutations from the
H&E sites.
So one of the issues with, let's say for example, the TCGA data,
is that
most genes,
they're just rare. Their mutations are rare.
Yes.
And then if you look at specific mutations that have impact,
that's even smaller.
Yes.
And
when people try to make predictions, they have to make a decision on whether or
not to include any of these mutations on the same gene into
their positive group or negative group.
And so I'm also wondering if part of the reason that
these approaches underperform is maybe because
we're not assessing impact correctly with-
You mean variant impact?
Yeah.
Whether the variants that are in TCGA are actually,
let's say, is a tumor suppressor, truly deleterious-
Yeah
... or are they a VU-S?
Yes.
All of those things are confounders and biases in the data sets.
And I think as we pick individual tasks, we're going to have to clean those up,
right? I think each one of those are going to be cleaned up.
And the one thing I've learned from the meeting so far, and maybe I'll share
at least my opinion on this topic,
is that the foundation models are super exciting,
but they don't meet the performance of task-specific, highly trained,
task-specific models.
The Campanella paper took a foundation model and layered
on additional task-specific data on board,
and that improved the performance.
And so I think we're going to have to do with rare entities, sarcomas and soft
tissue tumors, rare mutations, if you want to do that,
with a concerted effort. The idea that foundation models plus a language
model are just going to be able to generally answer all the questions,
those AUCs are maxing out at .7, .8.
I don't see them, for reasons you brought up and many others, going higher.
So if we want them to go higher, we're actually going to have to take a step back,
which is like the anti-foundation model philosophy, and train
specific task-specific models.
I think that's where we're going to have to go,
and you're going to need a molecular pathologist to help you with variant
annotation.
Thank you.
I think we're out of time, so have a great rest of the AACR.
Thank you everyone for staying. Anyone who wants to come up, please come up.
I'm happy to stay late.